[Musik]
wir sind heute hier um die prallen
stärke wurde das jägerbataillon
steiermark mit 571 soldaten übt ein
wichtiger szenario den schutz weil man
nur sagen kann danke an die
milizsoldaten die bereit sind neben
ihrem zivilberuf auch noch den beruf der
soldaten aus zimmer war danke auch an
die unternehmen die das ermöglichen
ich sage auch als verteidigungsminister
ist es mir wichtig die miliz auch den
stellenwert zu geben den sie braucht
nicht als soldat zweiter klasse zu
gelten sondern als gleichwertig auch mit
der berufs karte angesehen zu sein warum
weil sie auch gemeinsam in den einsatz
geben würden deshalb darf es hier keine
abstriche bei der ausrüstung beim gerät
geben
dafür werde ich kämpfen
[Musik]